le défi dans le fond c'était de manger
pour deux dollars par jour par
l'intérieur de un mois donc avec 60
dollars manger pendant 30 jours
je vais manger sainement je voulais
montrer que dans le fond on peut manger
bien même quand on pas nécessairement
beaucoup d'argent tc pas c'est pas vrai
que quand t'as pas d'argent tu es obligé
de manger des saucisses a écrit tout le
temps j'ai cuisiné beaucoup j'ai eu
aucun gaspillage pendant mon amour au
lieu que ce soit moi qui choisis c'est
exactement les aliments que je veux
manger plus primés qu'est ce qui était
vraiment pas cher j'ai composé avec
j'avais des courgettes farcies
dans le fond le plat au complet si je
regarde ce qu'est ce que j'ai marqué
sall a coûté 26 ou de lentilles
quat'sous d'oignons tranche ou de riz 3
crochète ça coûtait 5 en dessous ça a
coûté 5 en dessous pour une canne
notamment
ça fait une haie 43 avec tous leurs
avons mis 43 je mange en deux fois ce
que j'avais calculé ça fait soixante et
un sou pour la moitié de ça